With the stellar success of the Iron Man film
franchise, it's easy to forget that the Golden
Avenger wasn't always the major player in
the Marvel Universe that he is now.
The character's never exactly been a C-lister,
but until Robert Downey Jr. infused the role
with his irresistible humor and charisma,
you couldn't exactly call him an A-lister
either.
Because so much of the superhero's popularity
is based on the films, it's easy to forget
how much the source material differs from
what you've seen on the big screen.
So as a little reminder, here's the untold
truth of Iron Man.
A different setting
The opening scene of 2008's Iron Man is set
in Afghanistan, where Tony Stark is showcasing
his weapons technology.
But most Americans probably didn't even know
the name "Afghanistan" in 1963.
Instead, Tony Stark's origin in Tales of Suspense
#39 was set in a more recognizable locale
to readers of that time: Vietnam.
According to Stan Lee, his goals for the story
of Tony Stark made Vietnam a fitting setting.
Lee knew exactly who the Marvel readership
was and he wanted to create a character that
challenged both himself and his readers.
"I'm gonna come up with a character who represents
everything everybody hates and I'm gonna shove
it down their throats."
A boy and his dog
If you only know Iron Man from the movies,
you may be surprised to learn that, for the
majority of his existence, Stark kept his
superheroic identity a secret.
To the rest of the world, Iron Man was actually
Tony Stark's bodyguard, a nameless good samaritan
keeping the super-rich Stark safe.
"Do you honestly expect us to believe that
he was just a bodyguard in a suit that conveniently
appeared?
Despite the fact that…
"I know that it's confusing."
Iron Man didn't reveal his true identity until
2002's Iron Man #400, when he donned his armor
in public without any attempt to hide.
Despite what you might think, it wasn't because
of a villain's blackmail or anything; he just
did it to save a dog.
In the story, Stark notices a dog about to
get hit by a bank robber's car and leaps into
the fray at the cost of his secret identity.
Now that's a lucky pooch.
"Truth is..."
"I am Iron Man."
You're Fired!
For a CEO and billionaire, Tony Stark isn't
great at keeping jobs.
In 2004's Iron Man #78, Tony Stark was confirmed
as the United States Secretary of Defense.
His appointment was short-lived, however.
As part of the Avengers Disassembled event
which featured the Scarlet Witch using her
powers to destroy the team, Stark found himself
magically drunk at the podium of the UN.
The drunk Stark became quickly enraged and
threatened a visiting politician.
Even for politics, threatening visiting dignitaries
with laser blasts was just a step too far,
and he soon lost the cabinet position.
Seems fair.
But that wouldn't be his last high-profile
appointment.
In 2007, at the end of Civil War #7, Stark
was named Director of S.H.I.E.L.D.
Unfortunately, he would lose that position
by 2009, following Secret Invasion.
Making matters worse, he got replaced by Norman
Osborn, the Green Goblin.
How embarrassing.
How would you feel about getting replaced
by this guy?
"YOU KNOW HOW MUCH I'VE SACRIFICED?"
Yeesh.
Fighting Hawkeye
Iron Man is a founding member of the Avengers,
acts as their main source of finances, and
as the supplier of all the stuff they tend
to break.
He also has a knack for bringing in other
long-serving Avengers, like the arching Avenger
Hawkeye.
Clint Barton first found his way into the
Marvel Universe in 1964's Tales of Suspense
#57.
Enamored by the seductive Black Widow herself
a villain at the time Hawkeye fought Iron
Man to help her steal Stark's technology.
A year later, in Avengers #16, Hawkeye became
a hero as part of the new roster of Avengers
along with Captain America and two other former
villains, Quicksilver and the Scarlet Witch.
But just because Hawkeye was on the side of
the angels doesn't mean that he wouldn't fight
Iron Man again.
Hawkeye joined the ranks of another super
team, the Defenders, right before 1973's Avengers/Defenders
War broke out.
When the two teams squared off against each
other, it was Hawkeye and Iron Man who battled
in 1973's Defenders #9.
"Just can't seem to miss."
"First time for everything"
"Made you look."
A true Hulkbuster
Tony Stark and Bruce Banner might be "science
bros" in the MCU, but the two have gone head
to head more times than most friends.
Iron Man has even managed to get the upper
hand on a couple occasions.
Iron Man's first and most memorable victory
over the Hulk occurred in 1980's Iron Man
#132.
In the issue, Iron Man put 100 percent of
his armor's energy into a single punch, and
with it he was able to K.O. the Green Goliath.
Stark rendered the Hulk unconscious again
in 2009's Mighty Avengers #22 by blasting
the Hulk with an exploding rocket booster.
Ironically, as successful as the Hulkbuster
suit was in Avengers: Age of Ultron, Iron
Man has never been able to defeat the Hulk
while wearing the Hulkbuster suit in the comics.
Every Iron Man/Hulk fight involving the Hulkbuster
armor has ended in a cancelled fight, or with
the Hulk having busted the 'Buster.
"I'm sorry."
The Thorbuster Armor
You hear a lot about Tony Stark's Hulkbuster
armor, but the Hulk isn't the only fellow
Avenger that Iron Man developed a specific
armor to counter.
In Marvel's 2003 three-part mini-event Standoff,
Doctor Doom manipulated international events
to set Iron Man, Thor, and Captain America
against each other.
Not knowing how else he could even stand a
chance, Stark created his Thorbuster suit.
Powered by an Asgardian crystal that Thor
had previously given Stark as a gift, the
Thorbuster rig looked like a marriage between
Tony's classic red-and-gold suit and the Destroyer's
armor.
But ultimately it wasn't enough.
Thor destroyed the suit's reactor and Tony
ejected from the armor.
The only thing that seems to get "busted"
when Tony pulls out a "blankbuster" suit in
the comics seems to be the suit itself.
"Let's get you comfy.
You happy now?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!